and here's a girl right here you seem
like a nice girl hi everyone at king and
the sting
my name is ashley i'm from maine theo i
can't believe i missed you at the
airport
if i knew you were there i would
probably bring a banner for you
and divorce papers for my husband okay
just kidding
my question is primarily for brendan but
i would love everybody to weigh in
my son recently told me he wants to stop
playing soccer he has
four years he's 13 now and dive
back into the world of
jiu jitsu mma all of that he wants to be
a professional fighter
um i'm terrified because of
you know the risks and i know there are
risks with every sport but i am i'm
terrified
brendan risks shaub over here for me
how to best kind of get over that and
how to support him because i do want to
support him
thank you so much gang gang buzz buzz
buzz buzz young lady well my first
advice keep them away from big gene
yeah right now number one nashville
powerhouse
[Laughter]
uh your kid wants to remember he's 13.
if it's his passion i'd say let him run
with it but it's a tough go
it's a tough go you know how long did
you train brendan before you started
fighting
uh i was training for probably three
years and then i was
off to the races wow damn within a year
i was fighting golden gloves
and i was into jiu jitsu competitions
and then the ultimate fighter came who's
golden glove is a black guy
it sounds like it but it's a national
boxing tournament
turn up and i only had six months of
training in boxing they put me in that
tournament
i didn't even know they said golden
gloves next week i went i don't give a
[ __ ]
well we signed you up like oh [ __ ]
that's crazy that's my first competition
and i won it you did yep all knockouts
damn dude it's so violent brenden it was
a curse
why are we so violent yeah what do you
get at the end of the tutorial when you
get out of this
sweet belt i got this big ass belt
oh yeah well my dad has it hell yeah
dang you didn't even get to keep it
no damn oh uh but if your kid's into it
listen as long as your kid's passion
about something but fighting's a tough
go
man but i think he'll learn quick
whether or not he's into it for the
fighting or if he just likes the
training part of it
like you never know what's going to lead
to yeah also the chance him sticking
with it being a professional is not good
so who knows what think about it no kid
wants to do karate anymore
no they see the jiu jitsu 100 100 kid
wants to do
correct plus he might make some friends
make him tough probably give him some
confidence
riley mao actually is a taekwondo black
belt
no you should bring him into jiu-jitsu
with you
good correlation cat uh i don't know
you should let big jean get a hold of
him mcgee's ruthless dude
big jeans it's all ruthless man it's the
ruthless
it's danger bro but yeah i think it's i
mean i think it's it's neat for kids i
think i don't want my kids to do it but
really
no not at all if i would have gotten
into when i was young i think it would
have helped me with a lot of confidence
big difference though if they want to do
jiu jitsu or wrestling
go full go but if they want to do like
boxing and
mma and get hit in the head no yeah got
it
yes risky risky that'd be my fighting
name
risky vaughn ooh i like that
risk what does that even mean you did
all right dude
that could be your country name too in
nashville risky vong
risky yeah
i already have theovon and they're
already getting tickets to that
no you'll sell more if it's risky bombs
risk getting a bad name dude
that's a great nickname risky biscuit
risky vaughn
yep risky vaughn the life in time
[Music]